his artworks are big colorful and
eye-catching but a closer look shows
something more they're made of trash
Tomas tambo is a designer and artist who
proves that one man's trash is another
man's treasure all his sculptures and
projects are made of things that have
been thrown away I've been using
recycled materials my whole life and as
I grew older I still wanted to build a
lot of stuff and be creative and like
this but I still didn't have a lot of
money and I learned at that point that
it made no sense to go and buy it when I
could just find it Tomas sorts through
his latest acquisitions tense yoga mats
and sundry items left behind at a music
festival he's got plans for them in his
next project we're gonna make workshops
where people can make hats and like a
superhero masks out of the mess now when
I'm standing and and sorting it out also
get a little idea of okay maybe I can
put this one together with this one and
it can become this one first he goes
scavenging then he develops the project
to suit what he's found that's also how
he came up with the happy wall the wall
is made up of almost 2,000 analog pixels
made of bits of wood left over from the
roskilde festival stage dambo
constructed the interactive wall in
central Copenhagen in 2013 the idea
behind heavy wall is to allow people to
express themselves in in a big and
powerful way in a public space
passers-by were invited to photograph
their messages and post them on social
media with the hashtag happy wall over
7,000 photos of the happy wall were
uploaded in just one year if you write
something that the the general public
won't like then the general public will
just go and they'll flip the board and
so in this way it's in it's a democratic
way to chew
what you can see in the city and unlike
commercials which are defined by who has
the money and the means the 35 year old
artist is also keen for the public to
interact with his current installation
it's street art with a difference 52
bird houses made of recycled wood are
part of an open-air exhibition at the
Arkin museum of modern art that is if
they can be found well we chose Thomas
Dumbo to be part of this exhibition
because he is very much in accordance
with the way that we think at the museum
we think that the museum is there for
the public and Thomas Tampa really
employs the public he involves the
public and he communicates with the
level of the public so to speak and that
has really engaged the public a lot the
artist has installed some 3,500 bird
houses since he started building them in
2007 he's taken his recycling message
from Copenhagen as far as Lebanon this
street art is for the birds and
open-minded viewers since one of my
friends has been in jail for painting
graffiti I was inspired to do some kind
of a project but and when I put it up or
when I painted it or when i sticked it
at the wall or how we normally do in the
street art project and the people will
not like call the police but they would
instill instead call me and say thank
you his next project is also designed to
give people a positive experience with
recycling for an upcoming festival he's
planning a sculpture of a mountain with
a flowing water fall it'll be made of
6,000 wooden triangles he's found hidden
behind the waterfall will be a space for
meetings workshops and dancing where we
are recycling right now at like the
level we are as a world with real like a
beginner level you know we are really
really bad at it and I hope that my work
and can help us just come up a little
bit you know and and I hope that I also
will learn to get better they're true
doing it in
hopefully I have a lot of years left
where I can do like bigger and bigger
project because I have a lot of ideas
left Tomas Tomas fantastical creations
give new life to old things and he makes
people think twice about what they toss
out